"Spider-Man: No Way Home" is one of the most
thrilling movies in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
– but does any of it actually make sense?
When it comes to time travel, parallel universes,
and magic, anything is possible — and when
anything is possible, the rules for how things
work can get real confusing, real fast.
In order to reverse the effects of the movie's
first botched spell, Doctor Strange casts
another spell at the climax of the movie that
makes everyone in the multiverse forget that
the MCU's Peter Parker ever existed.
This complicated series of events can be tough
to wrap your head around.
In the end, Doctor Strange's spell in "No
Way Home" only raised more questions, even
as it resolved the multiverse-level catastrophe
at hand.
One of the most glaring questions raised by
the effects of Doctor Strange's spell is in
how it influences Happy Hogan.
A key ongoing subplot running throughout the
first two Tom Holland "Spider-Man" films is
Happy Hogan's budding relationship with Aunt
May.
The long-time accomplice to Tony Stark meets
May through Peter, and their relationship
grows from there.
Given Happy's ties to both Peter and May,
at first glance, it doesn't make much sense
that he would still remember her after Doctor
Strange casts his second spell.
Peter runs into Happy while visiting May's
grave after she is killed by the Green Goblin.
He doesn't recognize Peter, but he does briefly
explain that he met May "through Spider-Man."
Since Spider-Man still exists as a separate
entity from Peter in everyone's minds, Happy
would still have memories of working with
a young superhero on Avengers missions.
However, any inkling that that young superhero
is the man he's talking to at the graveside
is gone.
This fact is also hammered home in J. Jonah
Jameson's final rant, in which he explicitly
asks for the now-unknown Spider-Man to reveal
his true identity.
And so, even though the specialness of Happy's
bond with Peter through their connection to
May is gone, there is something nice about
him retaining memories of the woman he loved
— even if the details about who introduced
them are a bit fuzzier.
Some of the dialogue between Peter and Michelle
Jones-Watson near the end of "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" indicates that it is possible
for MJ, and presumably others, to remember
Peter even after the spell.
They only need to be reminded, something which
Peter is too chicken to do in the film's conclusion.
If that's the case, then wouldn't Mysterio's
video, which is broadcast at the end of "Spider-Man:
Far From Home," simply remind everyone that
Peter Parker both exists and that he is Spider-Man?
This is a question "No Way Home" never really
addresses; it is left up to the viewer's imagination
to fill in the gaps.
Presumably, Doctor Strange's spell could have
done a number of things to resolve this, including
altering reality to change the video or blocking
the true information from reaching people's
minds when they watch it.
In either case, it is assumed that the video
is incapable of reminding the world of Peter
Parker.
Even so, there's probably a good amount of
people who still believe that Spider-Man killed
Mysterio, attracted the alternate-universe
villains, and is actually a web-slinging menace.
The second spell also raises another question.
If his second spell — which makes everyone
in the universe forget Peter Parker's existence
— is capable of banishing the invaders coming
through from the multiverse, does it also
make the entire multiverse forget about every
Peter Parker?
This is another matter which "No Way Home"
doesn't directly address.
Like Mysterio's tape, this explanation requires
a bit of imagination since we don't know the
specifics of the ex-Sorcerer Supreme's spellcasting.
It's entirely possible that while the first
spell applied to every Peter Parker in every
timeline, the second only applies to the MCU's
Peter.
This way, the Raimi-verse and Webb-verse Peters
– AKA Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
– would still be remembered in their universes
while also being sent home safe and sound.
They might, however, forget about their adventure
with MCU Peter.
Only time will tell how this multiverse of
madness is going to shake out.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.